[Music]
Tom Cruise is always finding new ways to
top himself and Mission Impossible Ghost
Protocol he swung around on the world's
tallest building in Dubai and rogue
nation he clunk to the side of a plane
and held his breath underwater for about
three to six minutes claims very he's
taking it to another level in Fallout
the latest Mission Impossible movie
there was not one time in Mission
Impossible fallout that I used to
stunt-double on camera at any time the
movie everything we did it is Tom Cruise
100% in fallout he flies a helicopter
through mountains in New Zealand and
rides a motorcycle through the narrow
streets of Paris but the biggest feat he
actually jumped out of a plane crews
pulled off what is known as a halo jump
that stands for high altitude low
opening this jump is used by the
military to get into areas undetected to
achieve this you jump from as high as
you can but then open your parachute as
low as you can in the scene Ethan Hunt
and his crew need to land safely and
sneakily on a rooftop to get into an
event in Paris in reality the secrets
was shot in Abu Dhabi in the United Arab
Emirates according to the stunt team
cruises the first actor to do a halo
jump on camera here's how they made the
breathtaking sequence possible every
mission movie creates new challenges
you've always got to make it bigger and
better this is Wayde Eastwood he was the
stunt coordinator on fallout he also
worked with crews on the last two
mission movies as well as the mummy and
edge of tomorrow my job is to negate as
much risk from the stunt as possible
without losing the visual effect
he helped get crews ready to pull off
the most ambitious stunt of his career
to get him ready
they built a wind tunnel on set one of
the world's largest for crews to train
in crews already had some experience in
sport jumping but he never did anything
quite like this in addition crews jumped
out of a plane a few times a day
Eastwood estimates that crews jumped
more than 100 times on camera each part
of that sequence had to be perfect and
we got 99% clothes on so many takes but
there was definitely more to give
the crew developed a special helmet for
crews that both allowed them to film him
properly and make sure he could breathe
that altitude with a regular halo helmet
you wouldn't be able to tell who it was
under the mask it would have a light
source away actually see the characters
in the air otherwise you can't see me
the expression that paying attention the
Jeopardy crews battled factors such as
motion sickness and general exhaustion
from jumping out of a plane so many
times not to mention crews perform this
stunt with a broken ankle he broke it
while filming a chase scene in London
then only a limited window to get this
stunt right the camera operator jumped
out of the plane as well with a camera
on his head they plunged about 25,000 to
26,000 feet in the air
eventually they captured the perfect
shot the fact that they actually did it
in real life instead of in front of a
green screen is significant the benefit
of shooting the halo jump for real is
not to cheat the audience you can watch
modern movies out there and you can see
the fake actor in a wind tunnel are wise
with special effects fans blowing and
when the camera can only move in certain
ways and the green-screen burn is a
little bit weird on one side it's not
only cheating the audience but the
actors are cheated on but on their
performance and they can't deliver that
intensity that you see when you watch
this halo sequences its intense because
it's real
one thing is certain Tom Cruise never
phones it in Mission Impossible fall out
comes out on July 27th 2018
[Music]